Next we turn to the problem of mapping. That is given an
address, how do I find out whether the data is in the
cache, and how do I retrieve it? We'll start with a direct
mapped cache and a little notation. Let's suppose that we have two
to the m addresses that our cache block or cache line is
two to the n bytes. And that our cache has space for
two decay entries. All of these are always the power of two.
With these definitions, we'll call the lowest n bits the offset. They tell
us where within a given cache block, the memory we want,
is. And the rest of the bits, tell us the block
number. But how do we know where to look for this
block in the cache? We need some kind of hashing function.
Well, the easiest hashing function just looks at the lower order
bits and that is exactly what a direct mapping does. The
next k bit's the address tells the right index to look
for our data in, in the cache. Of course, this means
that multiple addresses will get hashed to the same location
within the cache. Given that our cache had to be
small, this was inevitable. But we need a way to
distinguish them. The solution is to use the tag, or the
higher order bit, to the address as a kind of
confirmation. Let's do a quick example. Suppose that we have an
m bit address space. And our cache block is two
bytes long, so we just have one bit for the offset,
and that there are four entries in our cache. So
we want two bits for our index. Then a direct mapping
would look something like this, where all the blue addresses would
get mapped to the blue block of the cache. The green
addresses would get mapped to the green, and so forth. We
can tell which of the color blocks is actually in the
cache by consulting the tag associated with the data in the
cache. In this example, the tag for the blue is zero,
because it's the 0th blue block that's in the cache.
Similarly, the tag for the green block is one. Because
it's the oneth green block that's in the cache and
the same principle holds for all the other colors, as well.